here's a story that will enrage and
shock you an immigrant employed a
tobacco shop in arlington virginia
exactly the sort of person the left is
always telling you
they defend defended himself against an
early morning burglary by firing three
warning shots at the burglars he wounded
one of them not fatally
in a shocking inversion of justice that
man the immigrant clerk is under house
arrest
and the man who owns the store says the
burglar the ringleader of the group who
broke in
has been cleared of all charges and
walks free tonight how does that work
exactly
joanne zuber owns the arlington smoke
shop in arlington virginia and we're
happy to have him back on the show
tonight mr zuber thank you so much for
coming on so
to the most shocking part first the man
who defended himself is under house
arrest but the burglar has been let out
are you sure
i am 100 sure this is so sad and this is
so shocking
the justice system is not working in
arlington virginia we went to court on
july 30th
and finally we see the video i hope that
the arlington county could share the
video exactly
and it's edited by the prosecutor's
office because they do not play the
volume
the reason why they don't play the
volume because they've broken so
violently that the volume will be enough
to get hamza off the charges
so what happens we saw the video three
masked men rush
in and he even said they all had knives
they all had weapons they were prepared
with masks
gloves and when they approached hamza
even had scream a warning
but they decided to ignore so when hamza
opened the bedroom door
he meets the face man face he meets the
guy face to face with a mask on
all black he admits it was pitch black
the criminal admit it was pitch black
and as soon as he meets face to face
what hamza does shoots him
close the door because there's three
people on there he closes the door
picks up the phone calls the police
opens the door again the guy is not on
the ground no more
they're actually running around the shop
so he shoots two more time
because he's scared for his life this
never happened to him before
and what happens was one of the guys
drags the other criminal out outside
that's when the officers arrived and
they put
hamza in jail and that's very sad and i
still can't believe it that
he was being protected by the
prosecutors and the prosecutor's office
is very
upset that i came on your show and speak
the truth
and now they're looking at the whole
thing a different way
they want to show me and hamza something
different i can't believe they're
protecting the criminal i'm sure if
their
criminals broke into their house they
would be doing 10 years in jail right
now
and poor hamza has a gps on him he has
to pay 350
out of his pocket every month for the
gps 800
child support poor guy he cannot take
his five-year-old daughter to the par he
cannot play soccer with his son
why the criminal right now on snapchat
on instagram smoking joint
celebrating that he's free and this
gives the community
juveniles out there hey you could go rob
and steal and the prosecutor will stand
next to you
and defend you and and put the real
people who work hard
who try to live the american dream and
put them in jail this
is very sad parissa tefti the prosecutor
hears this and joshua catcher
please look deep into this case you have
kids you understand i'm sure if the
criminals broke into your house this
would it would be a total
different thing and uh we're all also
still struggling
we have a court-appointed lawyer but we
definitely need help out there because
this is
sad for justice this is not this is
injustice really oh
it enrages me hearing that and the armed
robber is smoking weed on snapchat he's
well you're sitting on instagram and
he's sleeping in the store to protect it
and they break in and threaten him with
knives
defending yourself is now a crime the
whole thing is so grotesque and
orwellian
mr super i appreciate your coming on and
i hope that you will keep us
posted on what happens and i hope the
prosecutors who should be ashamed of
themselves
turn back from the course they've chosen
thank you thank you so much for standing
up for the truth god bless
it's shocking